[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission de débat qui décrypte chaque
semaine l'actualité politique au
sommaire dans le viseur de jacques de
guillebon et d'alexis poulain la place
de la france dans le monde et au sein de
l'union européenne
l'humiliation liées à l'annulation du
contrat du siècle par l'australie la
crise diplomatique qui en découlent à
quelques mois du début de sa présidence
à la tête de l'europe c'est un revers de
taille pour la politique extérieure des
manuels macro la france est elle
toujours une puissance mondiale
doit-elle renforcer sa place au sein de
lieux où ne compter que sur elle même
c'est le débat de la semaine
alexis poulin et jacques de guilbaut
s'attaquent ensuite aux primaires des
partis politiques alors que les
sympathisants écologistes ont emmené
l'inattendu sandrine rousseau au second
tour de leurs primaires que le ps
s'apprête à mener la sienne sans aucun
suspens ou que les républicains tardent
à définir leur candidat la question de
l'utilité de ces élections dans
l'élection se pose la primaire le
scrutin de trop c'est le monde d'après
mais d'abord retour sur le débat zemmour
mélenchon l'éditorialiste et le candidat
de la france insoumis se sont affrontés
dans une joute aux allures de débat
présidentiel qui est il ressorti du
débat ont-ils dessiner les contours des
grands thèmes de la campagne à venir
celle actu des éditos avec une première
question messieurs selon vous ces
deux-là peuvent-ils bouleversé l'agenda
de la campagne présidentielle
[Musique]
bonjour jacques jean alexis alors
bouleversé l'agenda de la campagne
présidentielle je sais pas mais au moins
il ya quelque chose qui se passe dans le
domaine de la guerre des idées la lutte
des idées c'est sûr que zemmour réveille
un peu la droite et marine le pen qui
s'est un peu assoupi et plusieurs luc
mélenchon est bien lui il est aussi
toujours là pour rappeler au camp de
gauche qui allait sujet de l'écologie et
d'autres qui méritent d'être traités de
manière un peu plus flamboyante que ce
qu'on voit dans les primaires oui j'ai
tout à fait d'accord je pense que cet
agenda qui pour l'instant n'existe pas
vraiment de la campagne présidentielle
et se passe rien la lr n'a pas encore
décidé ces candidats emmanuel macron
plane au dessus dans les sondages cet
agenda qui n'existe pas encore ils sont
en train de le créer tous les deux en
fait et en faisant ce qu'on peut appeler
vous ce déplacement la fenêtre
d'ouverture qui poussent des idées le
plus loin possible en pour que un
nouveau débat s'installe en france qui
est en fait ils font ça tous les deux en
fait on s'est alors c'est facile pour le
moment pour eric zemmour parce qu'il
n'est pas encore candidat officiel il
l'attend de se déclarer au bon moment
donc pour lui il a le vent en poupe on
en a même une overdose médiatique d'eric
zemmour on en parle ici mais parce qu'il
y avait le débat d'hier mais il ya une
limite à ça ce que j'ai vu hier dans le
débat mélenchon zemmour c'est qu'on
avait d'un côté un candidat politique
aguerri à cet exercice du débat
politique et de la présentation d'un
programme et en face un polémiste qui a
du mal à enlever le costume de polémiste
pour entrer dans la peau l'élu d'un
candidat avec des outrances dont il nous
a déjà habitué je voulais montrer un
premier extrait où il parle de djihad
plutôt que de délinquance là on est
vraiment dans le zemmour traditionnel
plutôt que zemmour candidats mois la
délinquance que nous vivons n'est pas
une délinquance c'est un jihad
c'est une guerre qui nous ait mené une
guerre de civilisation
une guerre de pillage une guerre de vol
une guerre de viol est une guerre de
deux meurtres une pente non j'ai pas
honte du tout je vais vous dire dans les
métros parisiens on a fait une enquête
il 77 et 75 % vous aurez pas ranger chat
surtout vous vous monsieur mélenchon
plus mais vous et moi aussi sceptique
vos chiffres on vous enverra mais ces
communes ont ils me jettent je continue
je m'étais ton nous d'accord mais on a
1000 crime je les reconnais c'est pas le
sujet mais si c'est pour le sujet csq de
saab et wi lan a lié à l'enregistrement
alors vous voulez vous répéter comme un
an mais la parole s'est ré musulmans et
les musulmans au djihad de chez moi je
manque de parler comme a dit tout et on
voit bien qu'il a dû mal effectivement
eric zemmour à sortir de cette ancienne
qu'il a sur l'islam les musulmans l'un
délinquance qui est un djihad là ça le
dessert mais complètement qu'il veut pas
aussi wii voit que ça marche en fait
avait fait ça depuis 15 ans plus le
courant d'affaires louis mais ça marche
je pense aussi pour l'instant convoyer
les sondages il à 10% dans le jeu dire
mélenchon lui baisse à 8 % fin bref il
semblerait dans le même étiage tous les
deux mais eric zemmour pousse ça et il
va jamais changer je pense avec la
compagnie bell comme ça si tenté qu'il
fasse une campagne et le souci c'est
qu'il part peut-être un peu tôt et les
gens en place et peut-être par cette
mobilisation ce refrain l'impression que
zemmour a remplacé le mot kovy doucet
depuis un an et demi on n'entendait que
ça maintenant on n'entend plus que
zemmour toute la journée dans chaque
phrase pourquoi qu'on parle il pleut
c'est zemmour il fait beau c'est
émouvant chiffres mélenchon parler de
disque rayé en dix ans on a l'impression
que vous dites tout le temps la même
chose et c'est vrai ça marchait quand il
avait son émission quand ils assez
tribune dans le figaro mais là quand il
est question d'un débat politique il
faut rentrer dans les thèmes du débat
faut s'adapter faut avoir des arguments
et là c'est évidemment tout le temps les
mêmes et tout le temps l'outrance
accords de latran salon innotrans était
de deux côtés si vous regardez bien
qu'on voie ce passage d'ailleurs en fait
le but de l'un et de l'autre était de
disqualifier l'autre en traitant d'
homophobes et misogynes etc ils se sont
envoyé la balle dans un passage assez
amusant le zemmouri ce temps ça existe
d'accord c'est pas mal existe oui oui ça
glisse un pays où les femmes soient
rabaissés un tri où il ya la peine de
mort qui vous plaît un pays où les
homosexuels sont punis et un pays où on
avait voulu par les inventions
internationale la ville islamique
l'arabie saoudite oui ça s'appelle aussi
les lieux mais c'est leur programme
mêlant chant ça c'est très bien parce
que c'est
parce que vous venez de décrire c'est
exactement les banlieues islamisés où
les femmes se font à surfer dessus quand
elles sont habillées en jupes c'est
clairement une caricature là aussi alors
le zemmouri stand à côté de djihad de
l'autre j'ai été déçu par ce débat parce
que j'attendais un débat intellectuel
d'idées et là où on flirtait sur le
débat par exemple de la guerre de
civilisation la crise de civilisation à
chaque fois les modérateurs était en
train de botter en touche il faut
avancer il faut avancer or je pense que
l'intérêt de ce débat entre un mélenchon
un zemmour c'est de rentrer dans le bien
fondé ou non d'une guerre de
civilisation est ce qu'elles existent
qu'est ce que c'est que la simulation
occidental est-ce qu'il existait ce que
derrière on a un projet de société et
tout ça était balayée d'un revers de
main pour dit il faut parler sécurité
faut parler finalement comme si vous
étiez tous les deux candidats bien sûr
mais la symbolique zemmour n'a pas
besoin de sortir de son propos puisque
ce discours de civilisation en question
c'est ce qu'attendent les gens et ce
sont dont il parle on est d'accord avec
lui ou non et ce dont parle mélenchon
est notre façon fait donc les mesures
tout le monde s'en fiche un peu emmanuel
macron encore une fois été élu non pas
sur des mesures mais sur ce qu'il était
sur ce qu'il apportait parce qu'il était
censé apporter et ce qu'il incarne et je
pense que là les deux candidats ont
vraiment eu raison de rester chacun dans
leur corps même si c'est des soins en
fait pour le spectateur le premier qu'on
nous a vendu ça comme un combat de catch
s'était filmé avant par des duels on a
l'impression qu'ils allaient monter sur
le ring et se passer quelque chose
d'incroyable qui allait avoir une
ceinture wbc à la fin pour l'un ou pour
l'autre et en fait non comme vous le
dites ils ont été interrompues à chaque
jour leur a fait une petite liste de
courses alors dites nous ce que vous
dites là dessus et c'est je pense qu'on
est rentré dans une autre ère de
politique s'est dit politique spectacle
oui il faut s'en désole beaucoup très
désolant ce qu il peut ne pas y avoir
d'idée mais là en l'occurrence on avait
deux personnes qui étaient capables sont
des orateurs l'un et l'autre étaient
capables d'exprimer justement comme vous
le dites et de réponse est dans le fond
et le spectacle aurait pu pour une fois
servir à quelque chose il ya eu un
passage au début sur la créolisation
d'un côté sur évidemment là le grand
remplacement qui défend eric zemmour qui
parle aussi de grands réchauffement
d'ailleurs alors dès qu'on parle et fait
tout est grand de tous tes grands voilà
le grand débat
le fait est que on a eu du mal à rentrer
dans les sujets et ce sujet de fond
finalement de dire mais si on parle de
cette thématique là est ce qu'elles ont
raison d'exister ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de faire tout un candidat ou un
potentiel candidat sur des névroses sur
une paranoïa et est-ce que derrière y'a
pas si vous qu'avez vous fait dire que
ces derniers rôles intenses quasi
propose française depuis 200 ans que je
trouve que tu es là où c'est intéressant
c'est alexis corbière qui a dit monsieur
zemmour on combat depuis 200 ans vous
avez deux français s'affrontent depuis
la révolution sociale ils incarnent
chacun un cas quand monsieur mélenchon
parle de religion de la france en tête
alors ça je sais vraiment pas très
d'accord entre guillemets peut-être
c'est être il y avait 10 ans s'était
passé exactement mais elle avait
vraiment de vision la vision laïciste
lourd de socialistes c'est de monsieur
mélenchon est en phase celle de la
france saura dire plus réactionnaires ou
plus pré révolutionnaire que défend eric
zemmour et c'est très intéressant ça
veut dire que c'est de france n'ont pas
disparu et qu'elle représente encore de
camp de paul comme ça qu'ils vont
peut-être servir à aimanter le reste de
l'échiquier politique pour lui donner un
sens en fait qu'on ne voyait plus moi je
crois que c'est l'intérêt du débat et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut limiter les
outrances parce qu'il ait un débat
philosophique au fond de comment on
envisage ce petit pays qu'est la france
on va en parler dans la deuxième partie
cultuelle pas tim est grand aussi mais
mais mais comment finalement on fait une
nation qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un pays les histoires étaient
importantes ils ont très peu parlé
d'histoire finalement malheureusement
alors qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que la
question est là sur la question
identitaire que même emmanuel macron on
veut remettre au centre du débat parce
que c'est dans son intérêt aussi un de
se poser finalement en arbitre il n'y a
pas de réponse et il ya beaucoup de
questions et c'est là que ce débat est
intéressant au delà de la politique
politicienne même si ils ont bien sûr
est amenée en faire et on voit bien on
en est là zemmour on a vu sur l'écologie
était très faible il rien à dire sur sur
le reste sur l'économie on a
l'impression qu'il suit les réformes des
modèles macron sans avoir grand chose à
dire on a l'impression que jean luc
mélenchon lui aussi son petit manuel du
parfait socialistes sur les questions
économiques et sur les questions
écologiques qu'il a rien à dire non plus
de 9 par rapport à ce qu'il disait il ya
20 ans ou ceux qui n'osent qui nous
traîne depuis depuis dix ans fait aimer
je pense que oui c'est plus profond que
ça en fait il n'ya pas d'échec et
politique aujourd'hui à emmanuel macron
tout seul ces deux personnes là en fait
sont ceux qui font surgir le débat on
n'entend pas marine le pen sur les
questions identitaires avaient pas là
nous disent la rue elle a peut-être
essayé de dire que oui l'immigration la
limitera si on peut qu'on rétablira
l'ordre enfin bref des banalités qui en
font quasiment passer pour une gauchiste
et côté des candidats putatifs de l air
qui sont valérie pécresse ou de lait
bertrand qui vont quasiment plus loin
qu'elles et mélenchon et zemmour quoi
qu'on en dise qu'il parce qu'ils ont lu
des livres je pense parce qu'ils ont un
côté intellectuel en fait remonter ce
débat un peu plus haut et c'est dans ce
sens là c'est très intéressant je trouve
sans aller dans les outrances mais qui
pousse chacun de leur côté vers
l'extrême droite claude ber extrême
gauche en fait je pense que ça sert à
nourrir quand même un petit peu c'est ce
débat c'est un débat qui manque
justement de polarisation du fait du en
même temps du fait aussi de cette
impasse qui est le maquereau nisme le
moment où une belle macro et telus c'est
la fin finalement de ce qu'ils voulaient
la droite sa cause or elle existe et
c'est elle devrait peut-être pas
s'appeler la droite la gauche puisque
ces deux visions d'une société de tapei
d'appel aura lieu à projets européens
bah revenons effet que c'est la réaction
la révolution se bat alors que tous les
deux 10 est révolutionnaire alors les la
révolution nationale de la côte et là je
fais oculaire de l'autre mais
effectivement on a affaire à des
révolutionnaires et on voit qu'il ya un
besoin de radicalité alors besoin
peut-être sur jouer mais il ya quelque
chose dans ce pays on le voit avec les
mouvements contestataires qui sont
nombreux un depuis l'élection des
malades maquereau et le fait que le
débat parlementaire et puis des places
oui on peut avoir des tribuns des gens
qui arrivent et qui vont remettre
justement ce débat entre la révolution
et la réaction et ben pourquoi pas ça
mon avis et c'est bon pour la politique
c'est bon pour le débat démocratique je
suis tout à fait d'accord et c'est là où
on voit le paradoxe les gens qui se
plaignent qu'eric zemmour soit là et se
payant même temps que le peuple ne soit
plus représenté je pense que c'est bien
qu'ils aient des tribuns vous le dites
ce qu'il soit là mélenchon les zemmour
pour représenter ce peuple en fait est
que ça donne une voix et que ça calme le
peuple un petit peu calmé mais au moins
qu'il ya un débat structuré
place au débat de la semaine après la
claque de l'annulation du contrat du
siècle et sa récupération par des pays
alliés états unis et grande bretagne
le poids de l'industrie française de
l'armement mais également la place de la
france dans le monde sont remises en
question at elle encore des alliés
d'hôtel quitté l'otan une défense
européenne peut-elle faire office
d'alternative mais lançons le débat par
une première question messieurs en 3
mots selon vous que révèle cette perte
du contrat du siècle
ça révèle que la france seule sait
jamais une bonne chose en fait ça révèle
aussi qu on a des alliés qu'on croyait
flammes si ab qui ne sont plus le fait
est qu'il faut se poser les questions de
nouvelles alliances
ça pose la question aussi je pense de la
façon de vendre de la france puisque
jean yves le drian était à la manoeuvre
déjà avant que ce contrat ne soit signé
puis il était là en tant que les
affaires étrangères je crois que la
france s'est un peu reposé sur ses
lauriers puisque l'australie avait
demandé davantage de gages navale groupe
avait tout faire pour les rassurer et
malgré sa
personne n'était au courant c'est une
décision politique prise au plus haut
niveau et tout le monde s'est retrouvé
totalement paralysé par les américains
qui manoeuvré en coulisse pendant des
mois oui mais ce qui est inquiétant pour
la france qui est le plus vieil allié
des américains comme on dit ça fait au
moins trois mandats pas quatre peut-être
depuis barack obama qui n'a eu deux
ailes trump est maintenant joe biden que
les américains se désintéresse de la
france de l'europe en général qui n'est
plus qu'un petit pion abbas al en fait
pour eux ce qu'il a toujours été
linverse delà de la politique ait voulu
mener la france du général de gaulle
manon lafrance non-alignés la france
indépendante et on est encore
indépendants d'ailleurs sans le dit pas
si on a des industries de défense sur
lesquels on est souverain heureusement
plus que n'importe quel autre pays mais
on n'arrive pas à s'imposer là dedans et
on est éliminé pour une cause plus
grande qui qui est pertinente à
d'ailleurs deux points de vue des
américains de se salir et de s'assurer
la chine bien sûr mais la manière dont
c'est fait est vraiment humiliante pour
la france je pense et on a intérêt à se
faire à nouveau écouter je crois que
l'humiliation elle n'est pas nouvelle
vous en parliez trois mandats il ya eu
les écoutes de la nsa qui écoutait les
dirigeants européens sous obama il n'y a
pas eu la de crise diplomatique majeure
on a l'impression que les présidents
français font la carpette devant les
présidents américains systématiquement
alors ils tapent du poing sur la table
pour le spectacle mais en réalité c'est
le fait tout se passe bien et au final
on n'a pas les moyens de la colère
diplomatique et on peut surtout pas
rompre avec l'allié américain mais ce
que ça dit c'est qu'évidemment il ya une
redistribution des cartes géopolitiques
majeurs et ça pose la question de l'otan
sur tout le temps qu'a été abordé
d'ailleurs dans le débat zemmour
mélenchon en disant mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait encore là dedans à quoi ça sert
aujourd'hui sachant que les américains
les états unis sont maintenant omnubilé
par la puissance chinoise par le
pacifique et que l'europe est devenue
simplement un sous terrain de jeu mais
qui n'a plus rien à voir avec l'europe
du rideau de fer l'adaptation avec
l'urss oui mais on sait qu'il ya quand
même une confrontation à bas bruit avec
la russie que c'est à ça que sert l'otan
en europe en grande partie aux
américains et que tous les pays de l'est
de l'europe sont à juste titre
historiquement angoissés par la rue cif
et c'est à ça que ça sert comme
boucliers à l'est sur leurs ailes est
mes éléments clés sur la baltique oui
c'est ça mais c'est certain que le
premier ennemi des états unis n'est pas
la russie ou le vin c'est pas elle qui a
les moyens d'être en tout cas c'est la
chine et je pense qu'on assiste aussi un
gros déploiement des puissances
maritimes en fait depuis pendant
longtemps vous avez cette théorie qui a
prévalu le ch et les géopoliticiens on
savait qu il faut c est l hinterland
c'est à dire que pour les américains il
faut jamais que le continent
eurasiatique soient rassemblés il faut
qu'ils contrôlent eux mêmes les
américains le milieu pour casser ce
continent réunis ce qui était le cas en
afghanistan ce qui était le cas en irak
ils ont peur en fait d'être marginalisés
si ça arrive aujourd'hui au japon c'est
sûr mais je pense qu'il s'en fiche un
petit peu de cg parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un gros déploiement plutôt
maritime on a des talos oak racing en
fait que sont le royaume uni l'australie
les etats-unis en fait qui se déploie
autour de la chine pour la circonscrire
et c'est là que va se jouer si on veut
dire le sort du monde dans les années
qui viennent la zone pacifique oui la
zone pacifique vraiment important mais
la france aussi qui est une énorme
puissance maritime qui ne fait pas assez
de ce côté là avec toujours la question
aussi de l'europe parce que derrière on
a eu aussi la fender ryan qui a défendu
mails macron mais les alliés européens
sont pas souvent là pour défendre on a
du mal à faire une défense européenne
avant son départ jean claude juncker
avait fait une loi sur de programmation
pour la défense européenne pour faire
des économies il ya eu très peu de
choses et on voit bien qu'on est de
toute façon concurrents sur la vente
d'armes et qu'on n'a pas du tout les
mêmes intérêts géopolitiques donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué de voir comment on
peut s'impliquer et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
sans l'otan est ce qu'on peut faire une
défense européenne qui ressemble à
quelque chose qui sert à quelque chose
sachant que maintenant la grande
bretagne qui est quand même un allié
essentiel aussi de la france pendant des
années regarde plutôt du côté américain
depuis le bric site est en train de
redistribuer aussi ses carpes en tant
que puissance maritime majeur
puisqu'elle a toujours été oui et ce qui
est paradoxal c'est que les principaux
alliés qu'on ait jamais eue en europe la
défense ont été les britanniques c'est
lui seul qui ont une armée capable de
s'aligner avec l'armée française alors
qu'ils ont jamais été au centre de
l'union européenne et qu'ils ont sans
santé maintenant donc on se retrouve
avec un allié qu'on a depuis dix ans
notamment avec les accords de lancaster
house on est censés partager de la
technologie partager des informations
qui a quitté totalement l'europe et qui
est tourné vers les états unis qui est
censé nous aider en afrique ou des
choses comme ça et qui a maintenant à
d'autres intérêts et d'ailleurs la
friction devrait en parler en fait c'est
à dire que la france se retrouve seul
quasiment fin nous soutiennent un petit
peu dans le sahel à combattre le
terrorisme islamiste et le certaines
révolutions locale pendant que le sort
du monde se joue encore une fois dans le
pacifique fait on est là on devrait être
en nouvelle calédonie on devrait être à
tahiti d'hier soir de rai tre dans un
autre endroit du monde et on est obligé
d'être ici parce que personne d'autre ne
le fait oui mais on n'a pas les moyens
non plus des opex à on voit sur la libye
c'est un fiasco également le mali on
voit les limites de l'intervention
française avec le coup que ça donne et
derrière on a l'impression d'un oui d'un
isolement de la france sur la scène
internationale avec en plus quelque
chose de grave entre l'image projetée et
l'image réelle c'est à dire qu'on a un
président français qui est toujours sur
le narratif de la france grandes
puissances grandes nations et puis il y
avait par exemple c'est eux ce qui fait
que nous un du daily mail qui faisait le
siège de la france le conseil de
sécurité à l'onu serait quasiment à
vendre on pourrait le proposer aux
allemands et c'est emmanuel macron avec
la parole qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut a dit
jamais de la vie mais bon si jamais
toujours est il que il ya le traité
d'aix la chapelle qui a encore davantage
intégré la politique diplomatique
française et allemande y avait déjà le
traité de versailles hors france et
allemagne ces deux pays qui n'ont pas du
tout les mêmes intérêts géostratégiques
dont je vois pas comment on peut on peut
avancer comme ça en promettant soit
siège à l'onu soit une diplomatie
intégrer on voit bien les limites de ça
il y en a jamais eu et puis on en
parlera après il ya le problème aussi
industriel tissu aussi économique de ces
pays l'un d'eux mais sur mac on sait
très bien ce que vous dites c'est
vraiment ils ont bears de belles paroles
depuis quatre ans et on n'a pas vu grand
chose et j'aimerais qu'on regarde
d'ailleurs le passage où il a fait son
grand discours à la sorbonne sur sur
l'union européenne il nous promettait
monts et merveilles dont on n'a rien vu
pour le moment
en attire de défense notre objectif doit
être la capacité d'action autonome de
l'europe en complément de l'otan une
coopération structurée permanente
permettant de prendre des engagements
accrus d'avancer ensemble et de mieux
nous coordonner mais aussi un fonds
européen de défense afin de financer nos
capacités et notre recherche au début de
la prochaine décennie l'europe devra
ainsi être doté d'une force commune
d'intervention d'un budget de défense
commun et d'une doctrine d'une doctrine
commune pour agir ah ouais c'est terme
et résonances et il venait d'arriver
effet son grand discours est d'ailleurs
quelques jours après angela merkel à
libon popo pas si vite on va pas du tout
faire comme ça et d'ailleurs on n'a pas
du tout fait comme ça sauf que mm macro
il va être président de l'union
européenne dans cette présidence
tournante à partir de janvier ça va lui
permettre de faire campagne sur cette
thématique et puis aussi de surfer sur
la fin de l'otan remettre sur la table
cette défense européenne commune
intégrée ce budget commun intégré ça
pose la question de la souveraineté
encore une fois parce qu'aujourd'hui oui
on a une industrie de défense qui
fonctionne même si on a ce fiasco des
sous marins on est quand même un des
pays les plus vendeurs d'armes on peut
s'en désoler mais toujours est il que
c'est une des forces de l'économie
française mais derrière on a une
industrialisation énorme en france 2,5
millions d'emplois qui sont parties en
quelques dizaines d'années depuis les
années 75 alors que l'allemagne a
préservé son tissu industriel et si vous
regardez la balance commerciale c'est la
même chose c'est à dire qu'en france on
a bien du mal à vendre parce que le
cac40 nos grandes entreprises un nouveau
fleuron est bien l débauche en france
elles suppriment des emplois l embauche
à l'international elles font des profits
certes pour l'économie française mais
pour ce qui est de l'emploi en france de
l'industrialisation en france il ya plus
personne vous avez tout à fait raison
oui mais je pense que je vaux pour en
revenir à l'europe en fait tout le monde
a pris conscience aujourd'hui l'europe
ne servait à rien fait sur ce plan là et
personne n'a quoi que ce soit à proposer
alors on voit bien que c'est un machin
général qui ne sert à rien surtout pas
pour la défense les allemands je pense
était secrètement réjoui de l'échec de
ces contrats français parce qu'ils
étaient quand même le concurrent au
début pour vendre aussi leurs
sous-marins à l'australie ce qui est
absurde au fait de pays comme ça qui
sont aussi proches et qu'ils sont censés
partager des convictions des relations
économiques qui est l'europe et chacun
leurs sous marins qui le vendent l'un
l'autre et ça m'a frappé en fait sur
cette critique de l'europe
une citation d'aquino morel que j'ai lu
récemment qu'ils étaient vous savez un
des conseillers de françois hollande on
peut imaginer quelqu'un qui soit parmi
les plus sociaux démocrates amoureux de
l'europe et qui disait récemment que les
fédéralistes qui prône un nouvel empire
européen pour faire face à la chine
oublient qu'un empire européen
signifierait la mort des nations qui
sont la chair et l'esprit de l'europe
donc même à gauche même dans cette
gauche là en fait on en arrive à se dire
que la nation doit être de retour en
dehors de l'europe et qu'il faut
commencer à y repenser on en revient à
un autre débat mélenchon est mort hier
mais qu' il ya c'est vraiment cette
question fait que peut se poser la
france 2 qui est tel quel moyen prend
tellement fait pour continuer à se
défendre dans ce monde où elle a plus
beaucoup d'alliés plus beaucoup d'amis
oui quels sont les alliés sûrs et
finalement est ce qu'ils sont en europe
et comment aussi parce que on voit bien
que la façon dont l'europe s'est faite
elle a été surtout un support au
développement de l'allemagne et à la
réunification avec la sphère d'influencé
allemande et la france a été écornée
risée dans les pays d'europe du sud avec
une dette cataclysmique et là j'attends
de voir ce qui va se passer avec la
dette qu vide avec la façon dont la
france à gérer et les autres pays
sachant que le plan de relance aura ses
limites et donc là il ya vraiment aucun
plan alors on aura encore des belles
déclarations emmanuel macron adore les
discours mais je pense que l'europe va
être au coeur de la campagne j'espère
qu'on n'en parlera autrement au delà de
l'europe de la défense bien entendu
puisque derrière c'est la question de la
nation c'est la question de la france et
la question aussi d'un projet commun au
delà de bruxelles qui est une
technocratie fune santé
[Musique]
et maintenant direction le monde d'après
sandrine rousseau les confettis nist
radical se retrouve au second tour de la
primaire écolo anne hidalgo candidate
désignée avant même le vote de la
primaire du ps mi-octobre et les
républicains qui s'apprête ce week-end à
voter pour définir comment voter à la
primaire en somme un vote dans un vote
dans un vote question monsieur la
primaire à quoi ça sert
à la primaire à quoi ça sert à faire des
débats de plateau ça sert aussi
peut-être à se mettre d'accord derrière
des portes fermées dans un parti ça sert
aussi à faire de la pub pour élever ça a
été une bonne occasion de se remettre
comme ça dans le champ médiatique et
puis de faire monter de nouvelles têtes
comme sandrine rousseau par exemple donc
ça sert ça sert à faire parler de soi
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
qu'ils aient fait monter sandrine
rousseau je sais pas mais bien le dire
là pour robert mon avis mais je pense
que oui dans les primaires ne servent à
rien en france elles sont on sait très
bien des calqué sur le système américain
dans lequel on est fait finie alors que
ce n'est pas du tout le même type de
parti qui existe là bas ces deux grosses
machines qui se met en branle une fois
tous les quatre ans et qui sinon dorment
mais si on regarde historiquement dans
les primaires depuis le temps qu'on est
pratique en france une seule fois sa a
dégagé un candidat qui est devenu une
prison dorée but et c'était vraiment
hollande où je suis pas sûr que ce soit
la meilleure nouvelle qui soit arrivée à
la france et si vous regardez même
françois hollande n'a pas réussi à
beaucoup dans la terre de son parti mais
déchirure que cette primaire avait
provoqué en 2011-2012 en la même chose
en tête en 2016 2017 pour les
républicains vous ai dit quand même
quatre millions et demi de personnes qui
étaient allés voter ce qui est quand
même gigantesque ça fait sortir
l'inattendu françois fillon ça s'est mal
terminée puisque les deux autres je
pense à ma jupe et nicolas sarkozy ne le
portez guerre dans leur coeur en fête et
ça dès commencé à détruire ce parti et
on a vu emmanuel macron qui lui n'a fait
primaire avec personne sinon avec
lui-même se faufiler et devenir ce qu'il
est mais bien sûr le problème je pense
que c'est un problème d'organisation
politique
deux grands partis ça n'existe pas en
france on voit l'atomisation un des
partis à gauche notamment où là c'est
encore pire qu'à droite avec l'idée de
dire mais pourquoi faire une primaire si
ce n'est pour dire ah ben on est capable
de présider on est capable d'aller plus
loin puisque des gens ont déjà voté au
somment nos primaires mais ça ne veut
rien dire primaires ouvertes congrès et
on voit bien que c'est même un caillou
dans la chaussure de des républicains
puisque la primaire a été inscrit dans
le parti les règles du parti et ils
savent plus trop quoi en faire sachant
que vous avez maintenant deux candidats
qui se veulent les candidats naturels
bertrand pécresse il y en a plein
d'autres mais ça ne suffit pas et le
débat d'idées encore une fois hyper
alors qu'il dormait vernet l'autre de
délai rappelons le encore une terre plus
c'est l'eau qui vont être leur candidat
mais oui les primaires servent en fait à
se tromper aux partis politiques ma
croire que l'art base militante qui est
de 20 milles ou trente mille personnes
et qui va décider du sort du candidat
refléterait ce qu'est la france alors
qu'en fait ce sont des gens extrêmement
militants extrêmement engagée qui sont
aujourd'hui encore les parties puisqu'il
faut vouloir y être on fait dans sa
partie aujourd'hui ça n'intéresse plus
personne et ça reflète en aucun cas ce
que la france je crois que les primaires
ça sert aussi à rassurer les politiques
quand ils voient le taux d'abstention
générale aux élections ils se disent là
au moins les gens ils payent pour voter
donc ils vont voter est quelque chose de
rassurant pour des gens qui vivent de la
politique alors qu'en réalité il ya une
vraie cassure entre les élites
politiques et la population qui se
désintéressent des votes la primaire ça
te concerne une infime partie finalement
de la population française des gens qui
sont politisés qui vote et qui votent en
plus aux primaires donc il ya quelque
chose là qui est en train de se créer
pour continuer un système qui est déjà
bien malade alors qu'en réalité il
faudrait peut-être faire autre chose
simplement recruter davantage de
militants assuré de la formation
politique s'assurer en fait que le débat
soit vivant au sein de grands partis or
personne aujourd'hui ne s'emploie à
créer de grands partis c'est vrai tlr
qui a toujours de la tour dans son sac
encore réussi à inventer les primaires
truc lorsqu'elle celles qui vont venir
c'est à dire qu'ils ont fait leur grand
sondage sur quinze mille sympathisants
mais bon ils ont déduit que c'était
xavier bertrand qui avait gagné la chose
moi je en lisant les chiffres j'ai
l'impression que les personnes
interrogées sont assez divisés sur les
personnalités qui sont là qui a telle
qualité qui à celle ci etc mais je vous
revois pas que xavier bertrand se
détache comme le lider maximo de la
droite mais comme ce vieux parti
gaulliste et quand même excellent dans
la manière de manipuler les élections
internes je pense qu'ils vont en fait
encore nous faire une belle
démonstration il se doit se retrouver en
décembre avec l'imbroglio aurait vu
qu'ils ont voulu qu'il soit fait qu'ils
auront décidé autour d'une table autour
de bonnes bouteilles mais le problème
des airs c'est un peu ça on se rappelle
tous de la coco la commission qui
revoyait les votes à l'époque il ya
vraiment quelque chose aussi du timing
c'est à dire que les campagnes
présidentielles ont changé on est dans
une campagne fluide rapide où il faut
réagir du tac au tac est capable de
sortir des carte de sa manche la ya un
timing qui qu'on doit respecter décembre
pour la primaire c'est encore ralentir
davantage l'émergence d'un candidat
crédible ou un mouvement populaire qui
pourrait être derrière ce ou cette
candidate oui oui on sent qu'ils sont
déboussolés et on en revient encore à ce
qu'on disait au début de cette émission
heureusement il ya des candidats un
petit peu hors parti est un système qui
viennent polariser sur ce débat qui pour
l'instant est assez vain d'un merci
jacques lasserre et la prochaine
c'est la fin du duel les éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]